work meeting school classes birthday
parties even blind dating clubbing and
weddings they're all happening on Zoom
the video conferencing app has become
the pandemics go to social network as
one third of the world's population is
in lockdown months ago zoom was just the
fast-growing start up in the somewhat
boring enterprise communication space
today zoom is one of the best performing
companies in the u.s. its daily users
have surged from 10 million last
December to 200 million this April and
as the company's share price has
dramatically risen so have security
issues but despite a number of companies
and governments cautioning against its
use zoom has become an integral part of
our lives in lockdown this is how June
went from a conferencing app to part of
the pandemics critical infrastructure
zoom was founded in 2011 by Eric yuyuan
a veteran engineer in the
videoconferencing business born in 1970
in China's Shandong Province yuan
overcame 8 denials on his u.s. visa
application before finally making it to
Silicon Valley in the late 90s I
appreciate the visa officer finally give
me a prove too complicated to come to
Silicon Valley I think Western is never
gave up he got a job at WebEx one of the
first tech companies that created a
working video conference platform in
2007 cisco acquired WebEx a senior
engineer there and he saw the rise of
the iPhone and all these iPhone
imitators had realized that video
conferencing really needed to start
getting on mobile and he proposed moving
that direction and Cisco wasn't
interested and so he left ended up
taking a bunch of engineers with him and
started zoom to do exactly that eight
years later in April 20 19 June went
public in the u.s. its share price
jumped 72 percent on the first day of
trading giving it a
valuation of sixteen billion dollars and
making you on a billionaire but you I
never thought his company would become a
household name until the covert nineteen
pandemic hit the world as billions of
people practice social distancing to
slow the spread of the virus not only
work but also school and social lives
have moved online zoom is really simple
to use it's really reliable and this is
something where it's a one click
experience you get an invitation of
meeting you click on it you're
automatically in the meeting if you need
to have a gigantic sort of video
conferencing meeting the zoom can handle
up to a hundred people and it's in it's
free product and then if you pay for the
enterprise tier product it can handle a
meeting of up to a thousand so it's that
combination of kind of ease-of-use
reliability and scale in addition the
technology offers a menu of digital
backdrops so you don't need to worry if
you're half dressed spouse or children
are in the webcam sightline zoom has
gained huge popularity but this has come
with significant challenges we are
working extremely hard right for almost
of Sarah Marsden so every day look at
the capacity traffic and how to you know
add more capacity and make sure that is
a service table so far zoom has mostly
handled a 20-fold surge in usage but
concerns about the platform's privacy
and security are rising a series of
reports revealed zooms multiple issues
including that the content of its video
chats was shared with ad tracking
companies its iPhone app was sending
user data to Facebook without alerting
users and it's claimed end
encryption wasn't true there are also
questions about the kind of information
that zoom meeting organizers could
gather and keep about zoom meeting
participants so there's a video
recording feature there's a video
transcribing feature these are all
things that do not require the explicit
permission of meeting participants to
trigger but there was something called
the attendee attention tracking tool
which is the slightly Orwellian feature
that allowed the meeting organizer to be
alerted if it seemed like meeting
participants weren't paying full
attention to the zoom meeting if they
basically clicked away from the browser
window where the zoom apples was playing
internet trolls are targeting zoom calls
online courses and virtual Church
gatherings were disrupted by zoom
bombers hackers joining calls to shout
racist phrases or share pornography
there were children there were elders
there were elders who just the week
prior have learned how to go on to zoom
and who after a week of sitting in their
own homes
isolated came to church and to be met
with races and hateful anti LGBT slurs
distressing zooms China links don't help
either as the us-china relationship
sours zoom is headquartered in San Jose
but it has several hundred employees at
a few locations in China a university
research paper revealed that the
companies sometimes routed meetings
through servers in China even when all
the participants were outside the
country raising concerns of Chinese
snooping after these series of
revelations the FBI warned of zoom
bombing for Taiwanese government banned
zoom and companies like Google and space
X stopped using the platform school
systems in Singapore in New York
temporarily banned zoom from being used
for home based learning but later went
back to using it with additional
safeguards the company was also sued by
user who claims it is illegally
disclosing personal information you one
has apologized and zoomed stepped up its
privacy and security measures it has
removed the attendee attention tracking
tool added features to let paying users
decide which countries their meetings
get routed through and let meeting
attendees report a user to help bust
zoom bombers zoom also bought key base a
company which makes a secure messaging
and file-sharing service to bolster
zooms encryption any conflict you can
private in secret and the use of
interviews usability privacy first
security trust that's a number of seeing
never one see we need to make chin
that's the bigs obscene I think he also
feels like this is that these issues
have arisen in large part because his
company has basically in a way then kind
of repurposed and requisitioned by the
public people are still using this in a
way the way Eric you want in fish and
they would but it's different people
using it in fairly different settings
and so I think what he would say is
they're just having to kind of make sure
that they account for these new uses
while many companies are struggling to
survive during the pandemic zoom has
prospered some of its newly added users
have become paying customers and some
corporate clients have upgraded possibly
adding a few hundred million US dollars
to its revenue one of the interesting
questions going forward you know if and
when life returns to some semblance of
normalcy
it's just what zoom will be you know
whether it will go back to being more of
a corporate business video conferencing
tool or whether it will remain this kind
of consumer household name kind of
product and what do we ask Eric about
that II very you know and of they said
he had no idea but so far zoom has
played a critical role in these trying
times at whatever came to my master of
every morning in 20 or 30 years when we
look back I want to every remember this
zoom is rather seen to have emeritus
whoever the restaurant work to keep it
any company on
as there's no quick fix for the pandemic
zoom meetings could be here to stay for
the foreseeable future
you